your business plan needs to also have
emotions attached to it what's emotion
okay so emotion could be enemy
is emotional
what enemy do you have that produces
emotion you ever made a list of 10
things people ever said to you that
really hurts and just kind of mess you
up a little bit you ever heard uh made a
list of 10 things people said that
really
felt very good the compliment like
genuine that you truly believe that
you're like you know my dad once and
said this to me till today i remember
this and i made a very big impact on my
life right it's emotional but enemy is a
driver
you know
jordan look for enemies kobe look for
enemies brady look for enemies it
produces something right
sometimes uh
if i want to get uh one of our guys in a
company to move it's my job to find an
enemy for them it's your job as a father
for your kids to sometimes find an enemy
that brings out the best in them because
the best positive distraction in life is
when you're in the pursuit of something
and you got a target that you're going
after maybe there's a little bit of
enemy behind it so again
less skill more will
less
you know
competition more enemy less you know who
we need to hire next more culture
less you know what our business plan is
more mission statement less about you
know what numbers we're going to put up
and write the business plan more what is
the vision so it's more on the emotion
side
and tapping on that emotional side when
all of a sudden
you'll feel it by the way when all of a
sudden you're like your eyes change
you know how you talk to somebody
in three different seasons of their
lives and you look at their eyes and you
say this person's uh defeated right now
huh
and you look at their eyes you're like
this person is very curious right now
and hungry
and you look at their eyes
my gosh this guy's so focused what the
hell is going on with those eyes
that's telling a story okay eyes is a
reflection of where we are here
this produces this
if this is clear people are going to
tell this yeah so what is this
logic no it's only emotion this is only
emotion this is not logic this is logic
this is emotion so if we can tap into
that that's when we start like even if
you started youtube channel there was a
reason behind it
you know it was more emotional it wasn't
logical right so that's the part we got
a time but we got to go back and you
know one time big papi went on a streak
of not hitting home runs for like a
couple hundred at bats and he was like
he was like this and the coach takes him
in and says look at your swing when you
hit 50-something home runs and look at
this swing you're so tight you're so
worried about striking out he says just
play loose
just open up a little bit play loose
just swing like you're dancing just
start dancing again you know sometimes
we play too tight and you're tight you
throw the ball
you know you fumble a video you you
fumble the ball versus you just gotta
dance sometimes we we we put too much
pressure of performing and crushing it
and killing it and competing that we
forget to dance
all of those unfortunately
are things that are reminders and
sometimes we are not reminded of those
things we need to be
recalibrated every once in a while if
you enjoyed this video i give a keynote
a few weeks ago in las vegas
specifically on the topic of cracking a
code to content creation if you've not
seen it click here to watch it take care
everybody bye
[Music]